what I want to do in this video is
introduce the idea of a universal set or
the universe that we care about and also
the idea of a complement or an absolute
complement and so if we're doing it as a
Venn diagram the universe is usually
depicted as some type of a rectangle
right over here and it itself is a set
and it usually is denoted with the
capital u you for universe not to be
confused with the union set notation and
you could say that the universe is all
possible things that could be in a set
including farm animals and kitchen
utensils and emotions and types of
Italian food or even types of food but
then that just becomes somewhat somewhat
crazy because you're literally thinking
of all possible things normally when
people talk about a universal set
they're talking about a universe of
things that they care about so the set
of all people or the set of all real
numbers or the set of all countries
whatever the discussion is being focused
on but will talk about in abstract terms
right now and let's say you have a
subset of that universal set so let's
say you have a subset of that universal
set set a and so set a is literally
contains everything everything that I
have just shaded in what we're going to
talk about now is the idea of a
complement or the absolute complement of
a + 1 and the way you could think about
this is this is the set of all things in
the universe in universe that aren't
that aren't that aren't in a and we've
already looked at ways of expressing
this the set of all things in the
universe that aren't in a we could also
write as a universal set - a once again
this is a capital u this is not the
union symbol right over here or we could
literally write this as U and then we
write that little slash looking thing
you slash a so how do we represent that
in the Venn diagram it'll be all the
stuff in you it would be all the stuff
in you that is not in a one way to think
about it you could think about it as the
relative complement of a that is in you
but when you're taking the relative
complement of something that is in the
universe
Versalles set you're really talking
about the absolute complement or when
people just talk about the compliment
that's what they're saying what's the
set of all the things in my universe
that are not that are not in a now let's
make things a little bit more concrete
by talking about sets of numbers once
again our sets we could have been
talking about sets of TV personalities
or sets of animals or whatever it might
be but numbers are a nice simple thing
to deal with and let's say that our
universe our universe that we care about
right over here is the set of integers
so our universe is a set of integers so
I'll write u capital u is equal to the
set of integers and this is a little bit
of an aside but the notation for the set
of integers tends to be a bold Z and
it's z fours all from German for
apparently integer and the bold is this
kind of weird-looking they call it
blackboard bold and so what
mathematicians use for different types
of sets of numbers and in fact I'll do a
little aside here to do that so for
example they might say they'll write R
like this for the set of real numbers
real numbers they'll write a Q in that
blackboard bold font so it looks
something like this they'll write the Q
it might look something like this this
would be the set of rational numbers and
you might say why Q for rational well
there's a couple of reasons when the R
is already taken up and Q for quotient a
rational number can be expressed as a
quotient of two integers and we just saw
you have your z fours all fours all or
integers the set the set of all integers
so our universal set the the universe
that we care about right now is integers
and let's define let's define a subset
of it let's call that subset I don't
know I've been let me put a user letter
that I haven't been using a lot let's
call it C the set C let's say it's equal
to negative 5 0 and positive 7 and I'm
obviously not drawing it to scale the
set of all integers is infinite while
the set C is a finite set but I'll just
kind of just draw it all that's our set
C right over there and let's think about
what is a member of C and what is not a
member of C so we know that negative 5
is a member of our set see this little
symbol right here this denotes
membership membership it looks a lot
like the Greek letter epsilon but it is
not the Greek letter epsilon this is
just literally means membership of a set
we know that 0 is a member of set of so
we know that 0 is a member of our set we
know that 7 is a member is a member of
our set now we also know some other
things we know that the number negative
8 is not is not a member of our set we
know that the number 53 is not a member
not a member of our set 53 is sitting
someplace out here we know the number 42
is not a member of our set 42 might be
sitting someplace out there now let's
think about C complement or the
complement of C C complement which is
the same thing as our universe minus C
which is the same thing as universe or
you could say the relative complement of
C in our universe these are all
equivalent notation what is this first
of all in our Venn diagram what's all
this stuff outside of our set outside of
our set C right over here and now
suddenly we know that negative 5
negative 5 it was a member of C so it
can't be a member of C complement so
negative 5 is not a member of C
complement 0 is not a member of C
complement 0 sits in C naught and C
complement negative or I could say 53 53
is a member of C complement it's outside
it's outside of seats in the universe
but outside of C 42 is a member of C
complement so anyway hopefully that
helps clear things up a little bit